Boston Harbor the North End awakes
quietly but that doesn't last long
this square mile is part of the original
Boston settled by the Puritans the North
End has since welcomed waves of Irish
Jewish and Italian immigrants there is
history here Paul Revere's house Old
North Church were lanterns one if by
land two if by sea signaled the arrival
of British troops in Boston Harbor it's
all part of Boston's famous Freedom
Trail history brings them through this
vibrant corner of the city the shops
cafes and restaurants bring them back
Oskar cafe Paradiso takes his gelato
very seriously and he doesn't get around
with his cappuccino either to make ways
to put this big bubble come out when the
big well come out it's over heated the
milk has no more flavor and if you can
just hear it to me it's done because I
hear the sound of milk
I don't need it thermometer the marvel
for people who doesn't know what's going
on Maria's pastry shop is run by sisters
Maria and Enza they've lived here for
more than 30 years like many longtime
North Enders Enza has noticed a recent
change in the local population
used to be just families now they're a
professor working people couples young
young people love the northern valleys
sections cause it's just like a small
town that's what I came from you know
looking from a small town and this is
just like you know everybody knows
everybody a house the neighborhood may
be changing but the flavor of Italy
still prevails as night falls visitors
and locals alike face a tough decision
where to eat and sometimes food isn't
all you get a walk through the North End
makes all your senses tingle